- Les travailleurs temporaires
et les milliers de demandeurs
d'asile traversant actuellement
le chemin Roxham ne seraient
pas touchés par le programme de
régularisation prévu par Ottawa
pour l'instant, selon
nos informations, au grand
désarroi de certains
groupes communautaires.
FRANTZ ANDRÉ, Comité d'act
des personnes sans statut
- Encore une fois, on leur dit :
"Désolé, mais vous ne serez pas
éligibles à ce programme-là."
Donc, je pense que c'est
irritantpas dire
scandaleux de voir que des gens
qui sont ici depuis des années
et on leur bloque encore
d'aller pouvoir dire
finalement : "Je suis résident,
je suis un citoyen
à part égale."
- Les critères exacts
ne sont pas encore définis.
Mais le programme toucherait
les sans-papiers, donc des
travailleurs avec des permis
ou des visas expirés ou encore
des réfugiés dont la demande
fusée et qui ne peuvent
retourner dans leur pays
d'origine en raison
d'un moratoire comme celui
décrété pour les Haïtiens
et les Afghans.
Ottawa songe à leur accorderle .
Jusqu'à 500 000 personnes
pourraient être visées.
MARJORIE VILLEFRANCHE, DG,
Maison d'Haïti
- Ce sont des pers
dans une espèce de no man's
land. Ils n'ont que le minimum
vital, donc qui est le permis
de travail; ils n'ont
le droitd'autre.
- Est-ce que l'éventuel
programme touchera
les sans-papiers du Québec?
Chose certaine, la provincea soe
d'immmigration.
- On va parler, entre autres,
d'immigration.
- Par exemple, François Legault
s'était opposé à élargir l'accès
au programme de régularisation
du statut des anges gardiens qui
ont fourni des soins durant les
premiers mois de la pandémie.
- Le problème, ce sont
les fameux seuils d'immigration.
Si on rajoute 50 000 personnes
ariser, on sauterait
de 50 000 à 100 000 du jour
au lendemain.
- Ce n'est pas la première
fois qu'Ottawa se prépare
à lancer un tel programme
de régularisation.
Mais jamais de cette ampleur.
Le nouveau gouvernement
du Québec ne s'est pas encore
prononcé sur la question.